[Music]
[Applause]
Marcellus Wiley former NFL defensive and
host of more to it the podcast on The
Dan Patrick Network he sat down with
Bruce Smith we'll talk about that in a
moment last time you got into a fight
Marcellus
oh uh 11th grade
um I'm not a fighter so I looked apart
but certainly if I ever had an
altercation I'm the one running first I
just don't believe in fighting at all
saw too many fights escalate to bad
experiences death experiences so I'm not
a fighter but in 11th grade I was
walking through uh it was the locker
room it's narrow walkway and another guy
just a regular student was walking and
you know how you got to do that cordial
turn like we both give 15 degrees we're
good he ain't giving me the 15 degrees
so we bumped shoulders and I'm like dude
and then he looked at me like he wanted
some action and that time I did cave in
and I gave him what he wanted and I gave
him the business and that was the last
time I ran a fight I've been in many
altercations many disputes many guys
have tested me but no fight since 11th
grade how silly are NFL fights
oh God I mean it's one you know it's
self-destruction because you're hitting
the guy with a helmet on you know he has
padding and you know you're not gonna
get a great punch off unless you pull a
Draymond Green Steve Smith singer other
than that it's just futile in terms of
what are you really proving so I never
got into fights in the NFL because I
knew the end game was
to be the most powerful in the locker
room so The Playmakers the ones who are
balling they don't have to fight why am
I fighting you already know go get my
Popeyes go get my go get my food go get
my Donuts that's to me to fight for to
be the most powerful the last guy you
would ever fight in the NFL was who
oh if I oh
um John Randall early uh Ray Lewis
Middle
um late in my career uh Sean Merriman
had a moment there where I was like yo I
don't know what he's on but uh
but uh the point is those three dudes
kind of stood out like yeah they playing
football a little more than the average
Joe James Harrison would scare me
you know what I know James Harrison he
is a teddy bear and I say that lightly
and with a lot of miles between us right
now but he's like since I know him I
know that that is a little bit of his
protection a little of this projection
not necessarily to the core but he'll
put hands on you for sure all right help
me understand this Mike Evans situation
you just got embarrassed he dropped the
football he had a sure touchdown he goes
off the field and two officials are
there talking to him what did you see
yeah I mean in that situation it's all
about the Optics the Integrity of the
game is more than just are you making
the right calls it's also the perception
of it all and just like with a player if
you saw a player jogging on a play you
would start to question the Integrity of
that play the Integrity of that player
and it's the same thing with a referee
after a contest we just don't want to
see you going up for an autograph
session it just can't go down not on the
NFL's watch and not what thousands of
people in plain view so in that
situation I know he probably thought hey
I'm in the tunnel the game's over what
does it matter but you got to be smarter
than that and so in that situation I
just blame the officials for really
compromising and undermining what the
Integrity of the game looks like what do
you expect from the Buccaneers given
what's happened and now they play
tomorrow night against Lamar Jackson I I
wondered how do you
how difficult is it to prepare for Lamar
Jackson I wondered if it was like when
you try to prepare for Army football
that you don't see it every week and but
when you see it it still is successful
yeah the most difficult thing is to find
that athlete that can represent what
Lamar Jackson is going to bring during
the game and there's no one on your team
so usually like when we play Michael
Vick we would find a receiver and then
hope he could throw and just like he
would run around and play quarterback
because we couldn't use our quarterbacks
and even that is not a proximity like
it's not going to assemble what you're
going to see in the game in the game
you're going to see something that's
blurry like we know what fast is but the
geometry it takes to go get a guy that
you have not seen with that level of
athleticism is hard to replicate so it's
going to be tough on the Bucks because
they're distracted right now and you can
see it through their play you can see it
through Tom Brady and his body language
it's the team that doesn't have his eyes
on the prize and that's why they're
having their struggles as a former
defensive player how do you know when
you got a quarterback
oh like he's defeated before the game is
over oh
oh what well first it you
wreck signal signal quarterback you get
it from his offensive line and you can
tell by how the depth of the offensive
lineman like are they really trying to
put their head to the belt of the next
offense lineman that means there's fear
because if not he'll just line up in the
normal formation but when they really
try to stretch it you know you got an
issue there we could get something done
then you start looking at the
quarterback and a lot of times it's the
Cadence if they're too cute with the
Cadence like
you're like oh dog you're gonna throw
y'all off more than me because he's
trying to play that game that cat Mouse
game but once you get a quarterback
ah the the funniest thing about them is
if it's a pocket passer he's shot like
he's not oh this is gonna be four
quarters of hell but if it's an athletic
quarterback I don't think you ever have
that guy tap out that guy never says
Uncle because he always can just draw up
a play because of his athleticism so I
hated going against guys who knew that
they could run because they always had
options we're talking Marcellus Wiley
his podcast more to it on The Dan
Patrick Podcast Network and you teased
this last week when I talked to you you
said you know we talk about a lot of
things you were supposed to be the next
Bruce Smith
and but you talked about the racism that
Bruce faced I had I had not heard that
before what made you go in that
direction
yeah I mean Bruce Smith amazing
obviously I think he's the greatest
defensive end of all time uh he's my
football father so it was a weird
introduction Bruce Smith and I because I
get drafted in the second round to the
Buffalo Bills from small School Columbia
and the headlines in Buffalo were the
next Bruce Smith and I'm reading the
headline too I'm like who are they
talking about
do y'all know I mean sex this dude gets
every year and it was funny at first our
relationship it wasn't a standoff
relationship but he made me earn my
stripes he had to see some talent and
potential and I showed him
um but I never thought I was gonna be
the next Bruce Smith I mean that's like
playing basketball like I'm gonna be the
next Michael Jordan it's like ah he
might be great but you might not get to
that level so knowing Bruce to knowing
everything he's been through it was
surprising to me doing my research for
the podcast that Bruce Smith had
experienced racism in Buffalo the I
never experienced anything like that and
for it to be full circle for everything
that's happening in Buffalo and what
happened with the massacre at the
grocery store Bruce Smith really felt
that right in his heart because of his
experience while he played he was
getting letters uh he was having some
experiences to the point where he
thought about getting traded he demanded
the trade that didn't go through and try
to protect his family in that moment so
it's interesting to see him go through
that 30 40 years ago and still have some
some evidence what is it like to stand
there and somebody's yelling at you and
they can say whatever they want to yell
at you and there's nothing you can do
yeah man I I'm desensitized to it and
I'm not trying to be tough I just don't
care enough about what someone else says
in competition to what I think about
myself so every time someone says
something to me that's disparaging I'm
like ah that has to battle what I think
of myself and that doesn't mean that
they're always wrong it just means I'm
not going to let you get to me so I
always tell people this is what a
football game is like depends on
perspective
if you're on the field you only hear two
things
but if you're in the stands you don't
hear
or boo you hear that mother oh he sucks
oh his mama ain't nothing and it all
kind of translates and funnels into just
cheers and booze so when you have
someone in your face and they're trying
to obviously just undress you
I always have the biggest cheerleaders
in my eyes in my ears saying nah
Marcellus can't let them get to you bro
you got to be stronger than that
it's got to be difficult
um who's the uh guest next week on the
podcast
next week we have LaDainian Tomlinson
and LaDainian talking about humble
beginnings to become one of the greatest
running backs of our era of all time and
he was my teammate so he gets drafted
the year I am a free agent to San Diego
so you imagine my first day Landing
there as Junior Seau the veteran rest in
peace and Rodney Harrison great defense
and then we draft LaDainian Thomason and
Drew Brees and throw in a little Tim
Dwight on the side as well so we had a
loaded roster and it was a great
introduction and this is a great
interview with LaDainian but why is it
the Chargers always find the banana peel
they're they're the Charlie Brown of the
NFL they got so much talent and
everybody gets hurt
yeah I mean look there's no real answer
to that because like when people always
say winning culture you mean we're
winning and the guys in here are winners
like that can change the Chicago Bulls
used to have a winning culture look at
them now the Lakers used to have a
winning coach look at them now like I
just think it's about the horses I think
it's about the players with that said uh
the Chargers 14-2 remember that year I
know I do because that was the year
after I was cut and then they went 14-2
so I was in my feelings I was like damn
how'd they get that good without me but
but if you saw how it ended too they
didn't even win a playoff game that year
I don't have that real answer being a
former charger but hopeful that this is
our year you imagine being Matt Ryan you
win a game
you struggle against the Titans and now
they say he'll never play for the Colts
again
because of his contract they're
guaranteeing money next year they have
to do that but they don't want to pay
more than that therefore they're
shutting him down
and his career might be over
yeah ah
I blame everybody involved um let's
start with Matt Ryan Matt Ryan had to
know what his level of equity was still
in this league in terms of what is the
perception of Matt Ryan and it was
pretty low let's just be real even
though you can get a breath of fresh air
and that Resurgence and people reimagine
who you are he had to know he was pretty
low on his Equity so I blame him for
going to a situation where he had little
to no leash but I also blame them for
selling him on a situation that you
never think of a former franchise
quarterback going to a new destination
and not even getting half the season
like it can't go that bad for you and
you pull Matt Ryan in that moment so all
parties to me involved are guilty of not
necessarily speaking the truth or
acknowledging the real but what's that
like when you know your career is over
oh yeah you're talking to a guy who
knows that um uh it's weird like to be
The Walking Dead you know like it
happened to me in Dallas Bill Parcells
and it happened to me before the season
started I just didn't realize it
um
Bill Parcells walked with me I'm going
to get flozell Adams who was the house
the hotel the entire apartment building
and it's the worst experience when a
great player is your teammate because it
was flozel Adams and Larry Allen next to
each other I'm like damn wow if I had to
play against Dallas I have to do that
once a year I have to practice against
these dudes 60 reps a day so our first
rep against flozel and training camp
Parcells comes over because I'm the big
free agent he wants to see what I got
and I did a pass rush flozell just
consumed me just gobbled me up Jabba to
hunt me and I just went in this belly
disappeared and Parcells looked at me
said Wally is that all you got and I
looked at him and he went like this
and that
sh still Rings loud because that was the
moment I realized I didn't have six gear
anymore I wasn't that guy so now you're
going around and everyone's looking at
you different and you're the last one to
realize it but it happened to me in a
game I played against some young rookie
in Tennessee and the kid blocked the
hell out of me and then I'm going back
to the Huddle and he said damn Wiley
what happened to you
you fell off and then that with the
parcels ring let me know it's about over
bro
great to talk to you we look forward to
LaDainian Tomlinson on the podcast it's
called more to it danpatrick.com thank
you Marcellus great to talk to you all
right appreciate it guys all right buddy
um so you can go there the podcast is
available so running smoke new episode
of running smoke available today uh
check out the newsletter as well got a
uh great little heads up there with
something that we're very proud of we've
been working on it for over a year and
we'll give you a heads up if you've
signed up for the newsletter